the score exists for this film victor
shirts and your score from 1922. there
were some pretty good themes in that now
listen to me pretty good themes you know
the man that wrote but um
my personal take on it is that the score
is weak because it doesn't cue the
picture necessarily it's more uh
more like a series of put together
pieces that you just play one after the
other and so there are a great many uh
scenes with action and the love and
sinister and things going on behind the
scenes that this score
never addresses you never hear what
you're seeing so what i did with this
picture and what i want to do is take
those themes and utilize them throughout
in various places i've added some other
things that i think fit the action fit
the rhythm of the picture and i'm going
to try to do with this picture what we
call close queuing and that is following
all of the ups and downs and it keeps
you mighty busy in this picture because
it's a roller coaster of emotions of
fast things and then there's a sudden
break while they kiss and then they're
right back to the action again and
you've really got to be on top of it or
else you'll miss those things and i
think that's i think that's the magic of
getting this picture of getting the
score for this picture you can't just
start to play and just shut your eyes
and play
you